(audience cheers and claps)
- Hi!
- [Kelly] I know, I love it!
I had no idea you were
coming on until last night!
- I miss you so much! LA
feels your missing presence.
- Oh, I just loved it.
Last night, I was in bed
and I was like, "Oh, crap!
I was like, "I didn't know
Chrissy was coming on today."
- Honestly, I didn't even
know Dave was gonna be here.
(all laughing)
- You were like, "Wait,
what are you doing here?
"Oh, we're doing a show."
Now when did y'all first meet?
You've known each other for years, right?
Did you bond over food?
- 2004 when I first opened my restaurant.
- Yeah.
- Oh, here? So you were living here?
- I was living in New York
when I had first met John,
and yeah, I'm 38 now.
We've known each other 20 years.
We always hit up Momofuku Noodle Bar.
It was right by our house.
We lived in the East Village,
and we went there three,
four times a week,
and then I just fell in love with him.
- That's right.
- Great food.
Well, it's hard not to
fall in love with you,
especially being he cooks so well.
But where did your love of cooking start?
I'll start with you, David.
- I think with my mom.
She's just still was the
best cook I've ever met,
and that was the only way my
family sort of communicated was
through food.
Never anything else, but.
- There's some therapy in the workings!
- I think it's like our common
Asian bond, though, too.
I think a lot of, my family at least,
there weren't a lot of, like,
there wasn't a lot of physical affection,
kisses and I love yous,
but food was so important in our family.
And now, looking back and
having children, I do realize
that I'm very, I mean, I
smother them with love,
but they also get a ton of great food.
- I know, I think it's
so great when you learn
at such a young age how to
cook or to be in a kitchen
and how to, like, that's amazing.
I'm the opposite.
(Chrissy laughs)
You know.
But you have two boys. Do
they help in the kitchen now?
- Yes, four and two, Hugo and Gus.
- [Kelly] Taste test?
- They tell me what to cook.
They try to help, and
I'm their private chef,
and no matter what I make,
they almost never eat,
so it's a problem for me.
- That actually makes me feel good,
'cause when I do cook, I'm like,
do you know how hard this was for me?
I don't do this, and I
feel like I did a good job,
and they do not eat it.
And I'm like, it makes me feel good
that you're an actual chef.
And yeah, they just are like,
"Hard pass. Where's the mac and cheese?"
- Yeah, they want mac and cheese.
They want all shades of brown foods.
- Beige! My son eats nothing but beige!
- Beige anything.
Mine, it's gotten to the point
where I definitely take orders,
but I have to actually just,
at this point with Miles,
I said it the other day,
he doesn't eat vegetables.
And I mean, like, not a carrot stick.
It's just like a big like fight with him.
- My son! My son will not, yeah.
- [Chrissy] Thank you!
- He's like, absolutely not.
- No one wants to admit to that,
but then I was like, oh
no, it goes past that.
Like, I can offer him a root beer float.
Like, he doesn't wanna try that.
He doesn't wanna, I'm like,
"Please try this Coca-Cola."
And then I'm like, why am
I being, why am I trying?
It's just, it's crazy.
- No, but my son is the same, though.
I have to sneak it in into
a cup that's colorful,
that you can't tell what the color is.
And that's how I sneak it in.
It's like a juice or a
smoothie. He will not do it.
And he will smell it out and be like,
"This is a vegetable."
And he is, like, hard against it. Yeah.
- [Chrissy] Same.
- I mean, and it's like, I
could make him sit there,
you know, or whatever,
but it just doesn't work.
He'll sit me out.
- I know.
- He will be like, "Of,
I'll sit at this table
all night long."
- Before kids, you're like,
"If they don't eat what I make,
"then they're going to bed hungry."
I'm like, nope, no. "What
would you like, sir?"
(audience laughs)
- No, I will say if my son were here,
I'd have sent him to bed hungry.
(all laughing)
Because usually, I'm tired!
I'm like, I just did this.
If you didn't like it,
that's your problem.
(Chrissy laughs)
(audience laughs)
I'm like, "I made exactly what
you said!" and then whatever.
So you now have more family members
since you've been on the show now.
- So many!
- How's it going?
- We have two new little
babies. It's crazy, it's wild.
I love, it's chaotic, obviously.
Wren is six, just turned six
months, or sorry, seven months,
and Esti just turned a year.
And that small difference is
huge when they're that tiny.
And Luna and Miles are
just immersed in activities
and so many different things
and everybody's at this different stage.
- To keep up with as
a parent is very hard.
- Oh my God, the Girl Scouts stuff!
We're in cookie season.
- You want them to be
engaged. That's me, too.
But then it's just like, there's no way
to feasibly make all of these things.
- And I ask them, I say,
"What is one activity we should remove?"
And Miles is always like, "Tennis!"
He doesn't like tennis
'cause it's too one-on-one.
He can't get away with
any of his bull crap.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
And then with Luna, she's like, "Nothing."
And this one, she does everything.
- That's my daughter. Same thing.
Well, Esti just turned one,
and there were some photos from
her birthday like this one.
- [Chrissy] Yeah!
(audience coos)
You're like, "This one."
That's the only one
- Y'all make the cutest children
ever. They're so beautiful.
Wait, and then there's
this one. This one's fun.
(audience laughs and coos)
It seems expensive. What was broken?
- It was immediately after,
I honestly don't know
because that is a rental home.
And so then I realized
that they're probably
going to see that.
Or they saw it for sure.
But yeah, my reflex time,
I used to just like,
with Luna, like, oh, I would've
caught that in a second.
This one, I watched it go
boom-da, boom-da, boom-da,
and then I just let it happen.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Yeah, that's
having more than one kid.
You're like, it's fine.
- The worst is how proud she was after.
Usually, they cry or something.
She's just, yeah, she's our tough cookie.
- Yeah, I get it. Girls.
Girls and boys, they're so different.
That was a look at their new
show Chrissy and Dave Dine Out.
You can see it on Freeform and Hulu.
So explain the show to everybody.
- Well, Chrissy and I have been wanting
to do this together for a long time,
and we wanted to highlight
some of the best
restaurants in Los Angeles.
- There's so many good ones.
- So many.
And have great conversations
with very interesting, amazing people.
- Do you know what?
I was actually, I was
coming from a place of like,
there's nowhere good to eat anymore.
And then this guy comes up
with this incredible list,
and then it opened up my eyes, my palate,
my everything to different worlds.
Some of the chefs that
we got to eat, dine with,
and speak to completely changed my life,
completely changed my outlook.
I mean, I'm sure you know,
when it comes to work and food,
when it becomes like your
work, the passion can dull out
when you have four kids,
but it reignited my fire
for incredible food.
- Yeah, and I think
that's good timing as well
just 'cause I think the industry
was hit so hard with COVID.
All those restaurants. So many closed.
So to highlight them
is incredible as well.
- Yeah, we actually have
restaurants that are reopening now
because of the show, so.
- Oh, that's amazing! I
didn't even even know that.
That's crazy. But they
were hit really hard.
Like a lot of great places
went out. But how did you pick?
- There was an initial list of like 100,
and I don't think we could
have ever have done it justice,
so hopefully there's more seasons
so we can cover all
the awesome restaurants
that we love so much.
- Just put it on. You
don't have to watch it.
Just put it on the
television and just let it-
- Just get those ratings up.
- I'm like, I don't even
know how Nielsen works,
but I assume you're all Nielsen families.
- I do, too. I don't know
how they work, either.
Every time someone says
rating, I'm like, what?
I'm like, I dunno.
Anyway, you had the greatest exit at a job
that I've heard of.
So before becoming a chef, you
worked, like, an office job.
- I did.
- And how did this end, David?
- Well, I wanted to make
sure that I was gonna burn
all the bridges so I couldn't go back.
(audience laughs)
- Well done.
- And I'm gonna say,
I told everyone I was
gonna go to cooking school
so I had no choice,
but I got really drunk
at a Christmas party.
- [Chrissy] That'll do it.
- I told a lot of people
how I thought about the job,
and yeah.
- And amazingly enough,
they didn't ask you back.
- Yep, not a surprise.
- I know, but I feel like a lot of people,
I've heard people exiting jobs like this,
but I'm like, "That's such a goal!"
- I mean, very few people are inspired
by the movie Office Space,
but I certainly was.
- Oh my God, I love Office Space.
- Oh my gosh, yes! Fax
machine out the window, done.
- Or that traffic scene
in the very beginning.
It's so true. You get to
the lane and it stops.
Why?
- I know!
(indistinct) every time.
- Oh God, what a great movie.
Well, I have to say this, too.
John's birthday was last month.
John's greatest gift is you,
because I'm telling you what,
this party, first of all, was insane.
- Feel free to text him that.
- No, and then also, your gift.
We couldn't air your gift.
This is daytime TV, but I saw one of them-
(audience screams)
- [Chrissy] Oh my God!
(Chrissy screams indistinctly)
(audience claps)
- [Kelly] It's a big screen.
- If you know me, too,
I am not a performer.
- You're not.
You seem like you'd be like this person,
but you're not, like behind the scenes,
like you're actually more reserved,
so to see you give a lap
dance in front of people.
- They let me come the
night before for rehearsal,
and they're like, "Rehearsal?"
Like, "It's just a lap dance."
Like, "What are you thinking?"
And I was like, "No,
no, I need a rehearsal."
And we did it and having
to lie to John was so crazy
'cause and just the-
- Who was the rehearsal man for that?
- My stylist Alana.
So she was, I had to lick her face.
We did top to bottom rehearsal.
- Oh my God!
- And then I had 48 hours to plan it
because I didn't, it was
Christmas and I didn't realize.
I was like, oh my God, he's gonna be 45.
That's kind of a big deal.
And then I love 50 Cent,
so I figured that he should love 50 Cent.
(Chrissy laughs)
(audience laughs)
But he really does.
- He performed!
- Yes, and so that throwback,
because John and I have so many memories
at The Box in New York.
Have you been?
- No.
- Oh! Anyone been to The Box?
- Old school. Good times.
- Oh, man, guys, you don't
know what you're in for,
but it is incredible.
- I think we do now. We do!
- Yeah, that is the kind of stuff,
actually, that is tame for The Box.
- Well, now that's a
tease. Now I just wanna go.
- It was so much fun,
and they were so cool,
and 50 overdelivered and I
completely negotiated myself,
like probably three times the rate.
- Oh, like for him to show up?
- Yeah, it started out at a low number,
and then I took it to like
a, I'm a bad negotiator.
My first words were, "I want
you to feel well-compensated."
(Chrissy laughs)
(audience laughs)
- We are the same. I'm
not good at that either.
I have to have other
people make those calls.
- No, yeah, I got hives. Everything.
- Name your price.
We're the worst. Okay.
We have a food game next
'cause why not? Okay.
Are you down for a food game next?
- Very down.
- You're gonna have to
play anyway, but cool.
So let's do another commercial break.
Chrissy and Dave Dine Out
is on Freeform and Hulu.
Check it out, y'all. We'll be right back.